merci d'être là jean luc lemoine les
questions qu à tierra on les attend sans
les où les attentions les attendent à
dire que je pense que les
téléspectateurs attendent cette séquence
avec impatience nous un peu mou et vous
avez raison
oui oui parce que les masques vont
tomber aujourd'hui encore oui on va voir
ceux qui travaillent vraiment notamment
ah bah moi je voulais donner un alors
oui mais j'attends de voir je vous dis
alors eu le plaisir et surtout de suite
bonjour je m'appelle martin
cyril a déclaré que des nouveaux
chroniqueurs aller rejoindre l'équipe
l'année prochaine c'est bien mais est ce
qu'il serait possible de ne pas attendre
la rentrée car il y en a certains je ne
peux plus voir leur gueule
axa je comprends votre impatience martin
vous avez tout à fait raison il faut
renouveler l'équipe et vite car on va
pas se mentir
être chroniqueur c'est un métier qui use
pas par la charge de travail n'aurait
par l'exposition aux chansons de kenji
donc régulièrement cyril faire entrer
des nouvelles têtes et des nouveaux qu
eux aussi de temps en temps pour vous
comprenez bien la problématique je vous
ai fait un petit comparatif regarder
il vaut mieux
mais tendent à nous avant l'europe et je
me sentais
ap
je suis gêné
est ce que c'est
domingo comme les belles gabbana domino
j'adore ça se voit pas du tout que vous
n'aimez pas compris du tout dans vous
avez compris cyril m kenji eu beaucoup
sans doute trop cas le problème c'est
que quand cyril aime quelque chose bas
il partage
m
et ce qui est bien c'est paris vient de
perdre un tampon mais elle est contente
elle avait toujours le sourire celle ci
regarde là et bref c'est comme elle est
contente pas la trouver de quels types
continuer
il faut ça que pour la sécurité sociale
est chroniqueur de syrena c'est
considéré comme un accident du travail
mais bon je vais pas faire passer c'est
le point irresponsable fou du kenji non
non non il aime aussi bruno mars
j'adore faire ça ça fait tout le temps
restaurant les mecs vous connaissez pas
ouais j'adore ne se contente pas d'aimer
les chansons des autres ils en créent
aussi vous savez il ya deux semaines je
vous avait dévoilé la nouvelle invention
de cyril concernant bertrand chamerois
rappelez-vous ou rocky kaki blue dragon
tattoo kimura guti qui mourra goût tout
j'ai trouvé j'ai trouvé une nouvelle
chanson pour bertrand trottier antique
imoula goût tout tout tout tout petits à
goutte et bien je vous avais pas tout
dit quelqu'un nous sommes passés tout
près d'une catastrophe j'ai entouré un
homme regarde et franck appietto
directeur des divertissements deux des
huit
le calme est essentiel dans la suite de
l'histoire que 10 de l'histoire de dans
cette saga du gué ki moon le problème
quand on crée autant que siri c'est que
parfois il arrive ça il y aura bertrand
c'est le roi qui viendra et d'ailleurs
j'ai nouvelle vers les gets une vraie
chanson pop afro chamerois concentre
avec tout public ouais et je l'oublié
mais je vais sedar
c'est quoi déjà
gym ou non saisi mukwa qui dit déjà oui
mesdames et messieurs un drame s'est
joué à ce moment là imaginez c'est sur
une inspiration jacques brel avec ray ne
me quitte pas et dans l'instant suivant
avait oublié les paroles
la perte pour le patrimoine français
heureusement l'homme que j'ai entouré
tout à l'air était là en capitaux qui
lui a une oreille et mémoire donc à la
pause publicitaire suivantes y aille pas
trop quand même qu'il vient de boire je
me dise qu'il ya je crois qu'il y avait
un truc à fait comme ça en fait excuse
moi c'est qui qui moule des buts h au
sous sol et repas mais il repart
vraiment très à l'aise justifie qui
moule début de sa chanson en capitaux
qu'on embrasse il était sauvé par kiki
mou du directeur des divers crus les
métiers mais mais était ce suffisant
pour sauver la faire non pas pas sûr non
mais ça c'est magnifique ça c'est fort
qui kimura gouttes ou non c'est pas ça
mais là mais là qu'est mon kiki mou qui
mourra non je n'ai plus est ce qu'on
peut pas retrouver les déborde
non c'est pas caca mou c'est sûr c'était
dans l'avion hier c'est que tu me
deux heures c'est pas tout mais un
village c'est vraiment dans la tête
c'est bon bah je pense que tout le monde
l'attend mais c'est compliqué d'être
chroniqueur ne touche pas à mon poste 1
c'est beaucoup de boulot surtout les
jours de 4 hier ah oui la preuve avec
cette conversation volé entre deux
feignasses la fin je crois le mal
tu es je vous l'avais dit ou pas je vous
l'avais dit chez vous que les deux je
suis ou non on savait voilà et à venir
dans l'âme a quand même c'est vrai voilà
vous savez maintenant à quoi ça sert un
conducteur c'est un papier qui indique
aux chroniqueurs quand ils peuvent
dormir
et quand le programme de l'émission est
vraiment chargé jean michel et une autre
astuce pour passer un bon moment
alors oui alors ce mec est un génie vous
allez enfin savoir pourquoi l'autre jour
il avait l'air serein à
moi j'ai passé dans une émission
je sais vous inquiétez pas je me saoule
je m'étonnais je pense qu'il parlait de
thierry henry
moi je vois je vous le dis ça me fait
encore plus de peine si par les tirs et
parce que j'aime beaucoup c'est vous
n'avez pas l'esprit de camaraderie
station jean luc lemoine m'a dit en
début d'émission
il va falloir prendre des sanctions sur
jean michel mr sa vie est ce qui m'a
balancé tout à l'heure ouais mais il a
raison il a raison bien vu ce qui va
suivre ce cours est dans la merde
pasqua il faut parce qu'il faut
renouveler l'équipe et je pour une
raison essentielle c'est parce que la
plupart des chroniqueurs peuvent plus
sacrés en vérité bon alors par exemple
la touche pas à mon poste sans les
blagues de tirer une rumba ça serait
plus il touche pas à mon poste
non le seul problème c'est que
jean-michel il ne supporte plus ses
blagues et franchement ça se voit à
peine
non
pas besoin j'ai pas mesure en fait tout
drôle
c'est dans ma nature
l'émission il est mignon plus dirigeants
mais ça c'est un petit vent thierry o a
dû comprendre mais non il va tenter sa
chance c'est se demander de quelle
musique il allait mettre en sortie de
l'ubs ont regardé thierry sortie sur ma
route en sortira sous peu
enfin
du coup je te dis pour toutes les
prochaines
ce qui est plus magnifique c'est juste à
la fin où il met le pourri et loppsi
sourires de faux-cul derrière ces deux
là n'ont pas le petit sourire c'est la
part belle à voir la séquence est
magique regardez maintenant
malheureusement
allez je vous rassure thierry est
apprécié par les autres membres de la
bande a commencé le patron un vrai cela
doit vous avez dit tout à l'heure de
will travaillé notamment à télé 7 jours
oui mais voilà et bah beaucoup thierry
mais après avec cette nouvelle rubrique
les chroniqueurs vu par cyril hanouna
car c'est quand même lui qui en parle le
mieux est aujourd'hui pour inaugurer
thierry moreau c'est pareil c'est quoi
ça salut toi et télé 7 jours la plume
télévisuelle j'ai créé avec mons greg
ce n'est plus du tout de sa bonne chaire
ya une très belle des cliniciens coupet
en bref maintenant le le vendredi quand
julien courbet présent tu veux ça va je
vais vous livrer un secret bertrand et
toute la table et il a une oreille est
allé n'auriez ouais ce qui lui permet de
recevoir des messages du rédacteur en
chef
par contre pour lire un bon gars et il
fait comme il peut bertrand qui s'était
puis dans la télé réalité que dans le
bon sens
ils voulaient me raconter une mine and
ride plus et pariez mais ça je connais
c'est pas très poli ça quand même à non
franchement c'est pas digne de l'homme
le plus séduisant de france rappelle
surtout que c'est stupide car notre
george clooney en herbe a oublié qu'ils
pouvaient aussi communiquer avec la
régie en parlant dans son micro oui
oui
alors n'y a pas de trucage ya pas de
trucs un truc géronte vous avez fait sa
ba apparemment mais je croyais pas je
sais quoi
baj héros tétouan a compris ouais mais
oui désolé ça et même au plus haut il
est mignon chez toi c'est voué à moitié
pardonnée actionnaires et isabelle
morini-bosc une fois les élèves mardi
bosque nous a gratifié de quelques
belles interventions dans l'émission
enfin le journal de avant a fait c'était
une émission sur les
oui vraiment c'est très fort enfin
pendant coming next massiri là encore
une idée très originale
vous remarquerez au passage ses facultés
à créer quelque chose est à dire bonjour
aux gens tout de suite après l'air de
rien je peux jouer de la guitare thabeet
n'était pas ça le procès a refait la
réalité les schémas possibles dans le
conte peut pas faire ça à la télévision
encore d'autres explique arrive en
question il ya une autre question quel
est ce qu'on peut pas on pose la
question et on revient juste après au
gouvernement pose assise sur prêts je
suis vous voulez cela peut créer une
tension avant c'est bien la question que
pose la question
bonjour je m'appelle raquel j'aime
beaucoup mokhtar mais dans votre mission
jean michel mr a dit que c'était une
petite merde donc je voulais savoir est
ce que c'est vrai
sur les huit jean-luc ronron voilà oui
je pense que c'est nécessaire
depuis tout à l'heure tu as j'en ai fait
au pas bien il a essayé de venir voir
mokhtar vous le dit pendant la pub et le
tas n'a pas voulu parler autant vous
dire que la babouche brûle
bonjour je m'appelle raquel j'aime
beaucoup mokhtar mais dans votre mission
jean michel mr a dit que c'était une
petite merde donc je voulais savoir est
ce que c'est vrai alors je suis désolé
mais je peux pas vous laisser dire ça
raquel jean-michel n'a jamais dit que
mokhtar était une petite merde
il a disputé une sombre merde
rappelez-vous française et aux motardes
et tu nous avais tu
le punk une raclure de bidet son
beau-père touche à ton plutôt rade et
les rues là
en gros cas voilà merci on voit beau
parent voilà qui n'est pas bien mais on
n'est pas bien il faut le faire un bisou
donc ça c'était dans les dernières qui
affirment aimer ce que vous n'avez pas
vu c'est la torpeur de jean-michel après
parce que oui il aime bien se douter
mais de loin dans le dos alors pour se
racheter il s'est mis en tête dans
l'émission de trouver un mot sympa pour
mokhtar un petit poème
mais bon pour faire un poème il faut
déjà trouver une rime avec vous
puma puma
aucun
je fais une pause car ce fait à ce que
vous vous rendiez compte que jean-michel
vois pas le rapport entre mokhtar et
puma oui par contre avec bad paris - la
salle des rocheriaux c'est ça je
voudrais rassurer mokhtar jean-michel
t'aime beaucoup il fallait l'écouter
pour en concours de pompes et philippe
etchebest
il était à fond avec toi même après la
défaite
grâce à ces nouveaux
je sens que j'arrête pression de jean
michel mais ils ne pensent pas c'était
juste pour faire de la pub pour ce cqfd
ce soir sur des huit noms mais
jean-michel n'est pas méchant par contre
il souffre d'une maladie la langue de
petites ya quelques temps il me
reprochait d'être égocentré de faire
trop trop de cette fille c'est vrai tu
me l'a dit ça un peu oui
eh ben c'est bon c'était faux mais j'ai
quand même arrêter parce que c'est vrai
que confère selphy on peut avoir les
recours
mais telle rage le terrain oh la la
c'est possible mais c'est incroyable tu
sais bien
alors allez pour finir on me demande
souvent si on picole avant l'émission
près dans cet état là vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure pour ben c'est vrai qu'on
peut se poser la question
alors pour vérifier gerland ralenti
quelques images on aime bien bruno l
édition ne touche pas mon bistrot
moi je suis comme chez riscle c'est très
sympathique
ce proche mais le problème c'est que
c'est je pense que c'était pas un peu
trop culture d'autant plus que sinueux
il avait pas forcer à grossir le trait
tout ça tout romy aujourd'hui lancé vous
coucher mais laissons maintenant si vous
le voulez bien
madame andré dubosc s'exprimer vous
n'êtes plus tout revoir le temps encore
parce que c'était pas miser sur nrj12 et
les internés
non mais là je racontais commenge râble
après ma femme cester j'étais jeune
journaliste un smicard à nancy
l'abandonner siret et tout hôtesses
bouazizi le film est d'ailleurs
qu'est-ce qui se passe